4 That's the reason why I took part in it.
I took a picture and didn't use it as evidence.
It appeared like this using the imagination of Kyoho and curiosity as a
medium.The appearance and strength were all set by humans.Does it mean that the
image has materialized
?  There must have been times in your childhood when you heard rumors and were
terrified.In the
evening, when you were leaving school, a mobster would appear and kidnap the children and
drag them into the swamp.
When
we did, the fear of that time is still burned into our minds.In
fact, even now, I can't stop shivering.Instinctively
, I was scared of this unpleasant sweat
.
I'm just a young man, I didn't listen to my spiritual
power. He absorbs the power of what he fears and grows bigger
.  It's a job,
cooperation
rar
Your creation is also absorbed and the house is a sheet
No, wait a minute
, pull my hand.
I can't keep up with you,
so what made
you swim?